the nebula is a sculpture and it has a
sort of geometric multi-tiered matrix
that just slowly swims in the atrium of
the hotel it's really the most
complicated and mysterious thing if we
formed like Voltron Rubin would
definitely be the head I'm optimistic
that we pull it out it's gonna look
it's gonna look right it's been really
hairy what me worried
we
we weren't expecting this I certainly
did not envision being in this
particular spot ever because it's gonna
work
there's 445 cables they're going all
over the place it's this massive
topological problem I mean the point of
the weave was really to do all the
thinking ahead of time this is a recipe
yeah Reuben actually came through New
York in June and said he had a really
interesting problem hada has string
manipulandum a damn mistake of saying I
thought was interesting too and staying
up most of the night with him working on
diagrams I was like this is really easy
I can just solve in no time and and and
of course it was not really easy the
best ways always to solve it backwards
to figure out how you would unbuild it
once was Bill and so it's I started
writing scripts within blender to unveil
it string would you pull out first and
then which string would you pull out
after that and after that and basically
ended up with the recipe of how to
unweave it and and what we're doing now
is playing the unweave recipe backwards
our task has been to replicate the path
that all those wires take through the
scale-model with the actual wires on the
full-scale day so the cables come
through the the five-foot ring of high
overhead through the weave and then the
screw down to these little plates the
little plates are like a jigsaw puzzle
and they get kind of put back together
into the grid shape and it's just a way
to grab you know like 20 cables at a
time and move them all in to approximate
position rather than having to pull you
know one at a time 25 then we 91 and 423
and 411
you can't tell like that you close them
I think it is too chaotic this small
patch
I get the right amount we tried to run
the easier cables first but but after
doing a few of them you couldn't tell if
they were right and so he stopped and
brought everything through the weave we
want to go into the weave at the knotch
so if there's some crossing like this on
top of it we don't go underneath
anything I was thinking about how to get
the cables from the ring to the model
and I ended up on the phone with dan dan
was actually goat sitting and we like
ended up on the phone for hours just
like making sure that if we put it
through the ring and just all in fact
work there are pieces of wood they're
basically miniature versions of segments
of pulleys on the cable net it looks
like you need to 92 we had them routed
to to the islands and then we moved the
islands into the space on the cable net
near where the police that those cables
will actually attach to lie
the next step is to cut everything slack
just loosen all of them then we're gonna
have to cut all those coils loose Ruben
kept saying dos he's like I think we
should just take the coils out and just
lay the wires out take apart everybody
apart we're all like no dude keep them
in the coils that scared all of us we
were just like is he crazy like take
them out of the coils no way you think
out all those lines drop the cross yeah
the coils are nice and compact and
controlled and we can like see what's
going on and the concept of having them
all loose just totally out of our
comfort zone putting our faith in Ruben
that this is gonna work and we're gonna
try to keep them relatively untangled
even though that's a relative term
and tangled up in here got numerous
occurrence of the footage we're also
going to take the weave model to the
ground
look it's worse what we want to do is
take all these out to their sort of
respective locations we already ran into
one situation where the wire physically
wouldn't make it from the ring to its
pulleys this is cable cut too short if
there's not one or two more like that
I'll be obviously surprised why is that
cable coming from the symbol down
that's 278 The Fairly broke off of this
so it goes like this
this could go to there this could go to
there and this could throw it here
445 cables 445 wires in a pile right now
have a very narrow focus I'm really not
looking at the whole piece anymore I'm
just looking at these cables yeah
carry that whole mess on top of
everything right
yeah super slow watch everything super
slow we don't want to get a tangle and
try to force it we started pulling it
out there was this an absolutely
incredible tangle a lot of tangling
Soho this other cable is corn I know
that topologically I can pull those
islands out and the weaves gonna say the
same but I didn't know his weather in
fact they would tease out but luckily
the nylon coating just made it so
slippery and they just just slid
the Nylund Cody's better for the
longevity as a cable which is why it's
there but I didn't realize there's gonna
be such an advantage for this process so
I was lucky thank god this morning was a
little bit scary I mean when we started
pulling it out there was this absolutely
incredible tangle it looked like
disaster was right in front of us there
was a woman here where it looks pretty
unbelievable I never would have seen
those wires sorting themselves out and
Ruben saw it he saw it from you know
pretty much as soon as the pile was
there you could think about it and go
okay this is gonna work pretty amazing
there's stuff going on here that I never
would have thought was possible before
which is really cool once all these
cables are in the right position then we
all lift it up and attach weights to
each cable when all those weights on all
the cables and all the cables are going
from the grid you know in a straight
line up to the ring that'll be the you
know big moment where we can actually
see how good the weave is and how many
crosses there are and what we have to do
to fix it up
well you're only dragging 12,000 pounds
through space so just get on it
there are three tornado alerts over the
Dallas area right now tornado
tornadoes are forming around us get away
from all glass that's hard to do in this
space we're done we finally get some
light and now we got a stop and this is
just north of the Dallas County Jail and
the loose stare at Justice Center and
just west a believe of the anatole and
those hotels so you know we possibly
dodged a bullet there with a lot of
people in that area the lower artwork is
a matter of assembly we made 10,000
anodized cones it was intense
putting the jewels together itself is
super easy he's my favorite we did have
a slight problem with the flexibility in
the joints of the bundles of six and
five where they just weren't there
weren't articulating enough but but we
have a solution which is some I don't
know fourteen hundred split rings that
we're gonna put in there just to give it
a little bit more flexibility
for a good spot to sign it
when you guys plug this thing in we're
going to want to conduct something
called a zero amplitude test 10-4 we'll
stand by until you tell us your plugin
I mean unless somebody could come up
with electrician out of their thin air
could be one thing and they heard
another thing be anything I don't know
but it's not the end of the world it's a
double rating cause it's not the end of
the world it's a mistake on somebody's
part it's not the end of the world the
adapter was Briggs idea I think it's a
winner we'll make up a 1 foot long thing
which even on a male line that goes
I just have to plug this thing in a
screwdriver
you just need to follow somebody's
vision even if it sounds totally nuts
because the sounder pronounced
you know all these cabled numbers are
out in my head I don't remember any of
them anymore and right now I'm just just
looking at the piece and just enjoying
it
I think if you're with the right people
you can do anything
it looks so effortless it looks so easy
humans are weird you sort of forget
about all the misery we move on and just
sort of looking at the piece going
houses this is really great